حاجه كده ما نعلم بها نعم بس يا ابو كل
الناس دي وقعت والمراوح والبيت وقع وكل
شيء بس في الحصل
قصدت حاجه الحاصله ان شاء الله ما في ناس
يتعودتون مستشفى التركي
وعندها جرح كبير وعندها سكري رقدوها في
منور
وجارنا واحد يتوفى
وحوالينا كل العريش بتاع البيت كله اي زول
عتبته وقع ما في حاجه نحن يعني البيت نهار
نهاي ما في حاجه ثاني بيت النهار كله يعني
سبحان الله ما في ولا اي حاجه ولا معلقه
الحمد لله ربنا يعوضنا بابرك منه وان شاء
الله والجاي علينا ان شاء الله دخل عليه
ما عندها اي حاجه يعني
اي حاجه ناس نحن ساكنين في محل عشوائي
كله ما في حاجه يعني ولا نحن منتمين
الناس الناس في حالنا يعني نحن ناس في
حالنا ما عندنا حاجه يعني ايوه الضربه
جاده يعني سبحان الله ما حاجه سهله الحله
كلها البيوت كلها منهاره يعني اي زول
سبحان الله الحمد لله نحمد الله
ونحمد الله ونكون من عباد الشاكرين جاتنا
على كده والحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات